[Music]
now apparently this true story sir
Anthony Hopkins binge watched all of
Breaking Bad
yeah and binge watch it and he loved it
so much he wrote a glowing fan letter to
the show's lead actor Bryan Cranston
check this out he says this is a quote
your performance as Walter White was the
best acting I have ever seen ever
congratulations and my deepest respect
you are truly a great great actor which
is remarkable why guess I guess Anthony
Hopkins is in a really generous mood
these days cuz just last night I got a
voicemail from Sir Anthony Hopkins
now I haven't listened to it yet I
thought it would be good to listen to it
for the first time here on the air
very exciting let's give it a listen
good evening Conan this is Tony Hopkins
I had the pleasure of watching a full
week's worth of Conan episodes and I
must admit your performance as the
talk-show host Conan O'Brien is nothing
short of revelatory I was mesmerised by
your ability to convey an almost inhuman
neediness on camera no I don't own a 3d
television I could practically feel your
desperation leaping from the screen and
grabbing me by my lapels while shrieking
love me someone anyone love me
Olivier Brando De Niro all should bow at
your feet and worship your portrayal of
the spineless joyless clown known as
Conan O'Brien you are truly a great
great actress
[Applause]
[Music]
you are really good accurate thank you
why did I listen to it for the first
time on the air that was my mistake I
[Laughter]
wasn't gonna point that out